[music]
It's a lot of nerves,
but I'm really excited.
After three years
of having been here and
going through nursing school,
especially through
the pandemic,
has been a difficult time.
But after all our hard work,
I'm excited to see where
we're all going to be going over
the next couple of years.
Incredibly exciting.
Just seeing everyone out here,
being dressed in these gowns
feels like all the hard
work was worth it.
I don't really know
how to express, like,
all the emotion I'm feeling like
everything I've been through
in the last four years at Yale,
how hard the last two years were
and finally be here
I feel just sort of overcome
with just emotions,
really happy.
[band playing "Boola Boola"]
[cheering]
[cheers and applause]
I now ask you,
by your official act,
to confirm upon them,
these degrees.
[crowd cheering]